vous pratiquez un sport d'endurance de
force et de combat on en arrive donc à
ma question est-ce que la mise en scène
du corps peut transmettre des messages
politiques et est-ce que c'est ce que
vous faites
ça va et toi ça va
non toujours pas ça fait bizarre
c'est facile des vidéos
en face des trous voilà juste pour
mettre un peu si vous me permettez de
poils à gratter dans votre narratif
la box j'ai commencé avant tout à fait
c'est parfaitement exact vous aviez
peut-être déjà des choses à compenser à
ce moment là
Nagui pourquoi les auditeurs
prenaient-ils Bruno Guillon pour une
fille à ses débuts ah parce que son
pseudo c'était brunette deux parce qu'il
avait pas muet 3 parce que l'émission
avait été enregistré en vitesse
accélérée vitesse accélérée non
[Rires]
la bonne réponse Bruno la bonne réponse
c'est parce que j'avais pas muet parce
que vous aviez
j'ai commencé la box comme mon père est
mort
et pas du tout parce que simplement
parce que
ça m'a secoué comme ça secoue tous les
gens qui sont confrontés
et donc j'avais je me suis dit qu'il
fallait que je fasse un truc que je
faisais pas jusqu'à présent direction
Venise ou un homme à plonger dans un
canal du haut d'un immeuble
[Musique]
la vidéo n'a pas du tout fait rire le
maire de la ville qui lance un appel à
témoin sur Twitter pour retrouver le
plongeur et son complice qui filme la
scène deux hommes à qui il décernerait
bien certificat de stupidité
[Musique]
si vous pensez que il faut être Playboy
en France pour être élu j'ai quand même
quelques contre-exemples
alors aujourd'hui porte me fera me fera
moins rire mais suspensoir suspensoir ça
peut me tenir
on avait dit pas
les affaires
non pas pierre papier
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai une bouteille d'eau
ont tendance à changer de métier quand
les femmes deviennent trop nombreuses
pour le dire autrement quand la mixité
augmente concrètement ce qui est votre
cas donc
lorsque la proportion des femmes
augmente de 10% dans un emploi la
probabilité des hommes d'y rester chute
de 12% à noter les hommes sont deux fois
plus susceptibles de quitter un emploi
il y a 75% de femmes qu'un emploi
ignorait que 25% de femmes ce qui paraît
donc dingue mais ça s'explique on a eu
Laurent par exemple qui est parti
récemment qui était très bien non ça m'a
pas non non ça m'a pas refroidiature
[Rires]
pour vous occuper du jardin pour
s'occuper du jardin
[Rires]
la peur de travailler dans un boulot
féminisé et considéré comme un boulot où
il y aurait trop de femmes à leurs yeux
aux yeux des hommes la féminisation
serait considérée comme une
dévalorisation ce qui expliquerait donc
notamment pourquoi on trouve peu
d'hommes dans les métiers du Ker les
métiers
c'est pas gagné mais voilà qui va à
l'encontre d'une idée selon laquelle par
exemple les femmes sont naturellement
attirées vers les métiers du soin et les
hommes peuvent et bien en fait si on
s'en tient à cette étude c'est pas
uniquement ça bien sûr que c'est déjà
dit
alors donc une autre question vous êtes
chaque jour à la télévision à l'antenne
avec les paroles excellente émission
Nagui excellente émission le seul défaut
que c'est à VOUS Benjamin bravo vous
êtes comme bien traités
[Rires]
j'ai vraiment trop trop hâte de le voir
mais j'ai vraiment très peur
[Musique]
l'adrénaline elle a son comble
je vais faire un AVC oh mon dieu attends
Bruno oui Saint-Jean
à tête déclaré sa flamme à Nagui fruit
de la passion Francky Vincent Lady
Marmelade voulez-vous coucher avec moi
ou les Musclés la merguez partie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris comment ça c'est toi
c'est moi en fait comme je t'ai dit du
coup je te voyais triste en amour donc
je me suis dit je vais je vais lui faire
de quoi être heureuse le temps d'une
soirée et du coup j'ai décidé de créer
ce compte de Mickey
et de là le lendemain je t'ai vu j'étais
heureuse tu étais toute contente il
s'embrasse langoureusement dans une rue
de Tokyo comme si personne ne les
remarqué
pourtant tous les deux sont très connus
puisqu'il s'agit du chanteur harry
Styles et de la top model Emily
rattachowski un nouveau couple très
people peut-être qui surprend en tout
cas sur les réseaux sociaux le problème
avec la petite fille bleue bah c'est
quoi c'est ça de notoriété pas très
discret aujourd'hui
27 mars c'est aussi l'anniversaire d'un
monsieur je crois que ça s'appelle Kad
Merad et comédiens
je comprends pas je suis perdue je en
fait là je comprends pas ce qui se passe
en fait moi ce que je veux que tu
comprennes c'est que Miguel il existe
pas
[Musique]
je me rends compte qu'en fait pendant 7
mois c'est Maëva que j'ai dragué quoi
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale du
fromage et oui cet aliment qui donne à
n'importe qui la laine d'un prof de
techno
41 95% des Français consomme du fromage
au moins une fois par semaine la plus
grande marmite de rillettes de tous les
temps c'était le point d'orgue
évidemment du Printemps de la rillette
avec une marmite de 4 mètres de diamètre
et à l'intérieur plus d'une tonne 1072
kg de rillettes 12 artisans la main à la
pâte 4000 pots de rillettes produits
dont un quart ont été distribués
gratuitement à des associations c'était
donc de la rillette pour la bonne cause
ce week-end on n'aura jamais autant
parlé de rillettes c'est en France qu'on
réalise quand même les plus beaux
affinages je rappelle le principe de
base on laisse moisir le produit dans
une pièce sombre puis on le retourne une
fois par jour jusqu'à ce que la croûte
se forme dans un EHPAD on appelle ça le
service premium
merci